good afternoon my name is Michael
Lucchese I am a senior majoring in
American Studies and minoring in
journalism today I'm interested I'm
introducing Roger Kimball who is the
editor and publisher of the new
criterion and the publisher of encounter
books a contributor to Newman numerous
publications including The Wall Street
Journal the Saturday The Sunday
Telegraph and the American Spectator mr.
kimball blogs at Rogers rules on PJ
Mediacom he is editor co-editor or
author of a number of books including a
Ford history half a century of polemics
animate versions and illuminations
William F Buckley Jr omnibus the long
march how the cultural revolutions of
the 1960s changed America the fortunes
of permanence culture and anarchy in an
age of amnesia and the forthcoming Vox
Populi the perils and promises of
populism please join me in welcoming
Roger Kimball
[Applause]
thank you Michael
well it's great to be here at Hillsdale
had a very nice time I brought my son
along he's gone now but he's considering
coming here so let colic offski so I've
done a informal and decidedly
unscientific poll in my last few days
patting about the campus and I suspect
that leisure colic offski is not a
household name which makes it I makes me
all the more delighted to be able to pay
homage to my late friend and teacher
Kolakowski
was undoubtedly the greatest polish
philosopher of the last century so what
you might say as Kierkegaard once said
when somebody called him the greatest
Danish philosopher philosopher of his
age he said I'm the only Danish
philosopher but Kalahasti was much more
than an academic he was an apostle of
freedom a model of scholarly erudition
and what's most pertinent for our
discussion this week is that he was one
of the most articulate and effective
Scourge --is of that perhaps most
murderous ideology that the mind of man
has yet contrived I of course mean
Marxism Soviet Marxism in the debate
over Marxism in the twentieth century I
have no hesitation in saying that
kalahasti won hands down alas as he knew
all too well in the affairs of mankind
winning debates indeed rational argument
of any kind generally plays but an
insignificant role at least in the short
term
koulikov ski was just a few months shy
of as 82nd birthday when he died in July
of 2009 at his home in Oxford for anyone
inclined to despair that we live in an
intellectually diminished age
Kollek have ski provided a glittering
counter example he was an intellectual
giant what is even more extraordinary he
was an intellectual giant whose
accomplishments were widely celebrated
Calico ski died full of honours as well
as years he snapped up the coveted if
often visible MacArthur prize ditto the
Klug prize for lifetime achievement in
the humanities he walked away with a
cool 1 million dollars for that Bijou
then there were the innumerable degrees
honoris causa and lesser Awards honors
lectureships
and sundry recognition he received and
deserved them all born in ragam in
eastern Poland in 1927 Kolakowski was a
boy of 12 when the Nazis stormed into
Poland
I remember the destruction of the Warsaw
Ghetto he writes in an essay called
genocide and ideology which I saw from
the outside I lived among poles who were
active in helping Jews and who risked
their lives every day trying to save
those few they could from the inferno in
1945 the war over he joined the
Communist Party the Communists he had
been told were anti-fascists and at
first he believed it he studied and then
taught philosophy in Warsaw where he
also edited a scholarly journal but when
it came to communism Kolakowski found to
his sorrow that maturity begot doubts
doubts brought forth criticism and
criticism he discovered was a dangerous
commodity in Soviet control
Poland in 1954 Kalakaua was accused of
strain from the marxist-leninist
ideology a charge I have to admit that
his was eminently true
he was strained from the
marxist-leninist ideology in 1966 after
delivering a speech commemorating the
10th anniversary of the October thaw he
was expelled from the party with all the
usual ceremony the state-controlled
press launched a series of attacks on
the renegade he was removed from his
university chair for quote forming the
views of the youth in a manner contrary
to the official tendency of the country
in 1968 he went into exile his works
were promptly enrolled in the index of
forbidden authors and until 1981 could
be neither referred to nor cited
officially after leaving Poland koulikov
ski embarked on a career in the West he
made stops at Berkeley which gave him an
opportunity to learn firsthand about
firsthand about and therefore to despise
the mind-numbing New Left culture of the
1960s and 1970s at Yale where I met and
studied with him and then at the
University of Chicago and Oxford his
intellectual homes for the last decades
of his life throughout the 1980s he
aided and abetted the Solidarity
movement which was instrumental in
ridding Poland of its communist
oppressors it would be an injustice
however if this impressive scholarly
inventory were to obscure one of
kholokov skis most conspicuous gifts I
mean his sense of humor
this is a conference about Soviet
Communism so I won't dilate on this
aspect of kholokov skis work I would be
remiss however if I left out that aspect
of his work altogether so I'll leave you
with a single
tantalizing tidbit the title of an
to wit quote a comment on Heidegger's
comment on Nietzsche's elec ledged
comment on Hegel's comment on the power
of negativity
now this aura tunned pseudo scholarly
rubric neatly rushers Kolakowski into a
serious point in a famous interview with
dare Spiegel published in 1976 shortly
after his death Heidegger was at pains
to exonerate himself from his
association with the Nazis among other
things he suggested that anyone who had
ears to hear would know that he had
criticised the Nazi regime in the
lectures he delivered on Nietzsche and
the will to power after Hitler rose to
power it probably takes an ear subtler
than mine Kolakowski notes to hear this
criticism indeed Kolakowski shows that
Heidegger obliquely but clearly
expressed his commitment to the German
imperialist regime in those lectures
Kolakowski is of course best known as an
explicator and critic of Marxism and
it's spiritual allotropes hence his
place at this conference his magnum opus
main currents of Marxism is a
three-volume work of philosophical
demolition Sidney hook aptly called the
book Magisterial and so tis it is
typical that Kolakowski endeavoring to
explain the origin of dialectic starts
not with Rousseau or Hegel as most
commentators on Marx do but with
platanus and flourished around 240 AD
the middle volume of main currents
offers a detailed anatomy of Marx's
thought and the work concludes with a
survey of twentieth-century varieties
from the Marxism in action of Lenin
Trotsky Stalin and Mao to the bloviate
in theoretical Marxism of Luc Hawks
Sartre and the so-called Frank
school at present Kolakowski observed
and main currents alluding to Marx's
famous adage Marxism neither interprets
the world nor changes it it is merely a
repertoire of slogans serving to
organize various interests main currents
demonstrates how Marxism committed in
kala coughs keys words to the self
deification of mankind became the
greatest fantasy of our century it was
an idea he wrote that began in
Promethean humanism and culminated in
the monstrous tyranny of Stalinism as
such Marxism provides a permanently
valuable admonition about the dangers of
utopian schemes what colic offski called
in the concluding sentence of maine
currents the farcical aspect of Human
Bondage there were as Kolakowski
recognized many aspects to that farce as
is shown by his observation that one
should be as careful about believing in
a green utopia as in a red one I hope
that some charitably minded person will
send a copy of Maine currents to Al Gore
he would discover any number of
inconvenient truths between its covers a
corollary of kholokov skis criticism of
Marxism was his appreciation for the
virtues of capitalism as an
indispensable an enabler of freedom
although I should say here that I'm
reluctantly used the word capitalism
I would prefer the free market because
capitalism that word although not coined
by Marx was popularized by marks and
other Marxists as an it meant for them
essentially exploitation so I always
used the word with a slight reluctance
but it's gained such wide currency that
that
one can't avoid it entirely so the
free-market Kolakowski noted in 1995
developed spontaneously and organically
from the spread of Commerce nobody
planned it and it did not need an
all-embracing ideology
whereas socialism on the contrary was an
ideological construction ultimately
capitalism is human nature at work that
is man's greed is allowed to follow its
course
whereas socialism is an attempt to
institutionalize and enforce fraternity
what a terrible idea that would be it
seems obvious by now Golikov skee
continued that a society in which greed
is the main motivation of human action
for all of its repugnant and deplorable
aspects is in con el cerebro hood
whether in national or international
socialism those are very wise words it
is important to note that main currents
of Marxism is not of historical interest
only notwithstanding the collapse of the
Soviet Union
Marxism remains eminently worth studying
not least because its aspirations
continue to percolate in the dreams of
various utopian planners not to mention
various self-absorbed anti-capitalist
beneficiaries of capitalism you Dean go
to China or Cuba or Venezuela to
understand this just look at the
increasingly pink and authoritarian
complexion of the European Union the
repellent theories of Jeremy Corbyn or
indeed the stultifying
Marxist inspired intolerance that is
disfiguring so many Western universities
today in 2005 Kolakowski published a
collection of essays modestly tied
titled my correct views on everything
in the introduction he notes that
communism was not the crazy fantasy of a
few fanatics nor was it the result of
human stupidity and baseness it was a
real a very real part of the history of
the 20th century and we cannot
understand this history of ours without
understanding communism we cannot get
rid of this spectra by saying it was
just human stupidity or human corrupt
ability the specter is stronger than the
spells we can recast on it it might come
back a couple of years before kholokov
Sookie's death Oxford University Press
published a new omnibus edition of main
currents of Marxism all three volumes in
one the only edition was a brief new
preface by the author although only a
few pages long the preface is very much
worth reading it reminds us straight
away and this emerges as a theme of the
book that Marxist doctrine by calling
for the abolition of private property
and the more or less total subordination
of the market to state control provided
a good blueprint for converting human
society into a giant concentration camp
the abolition of the market
he wrote elsewhere means a gulag society
kholokov skis new preface also contains
an arresting aside about the book's
publication history written in Polish
between 1968 and 1976 when their
publication in Poland he said could only
be dreamed of the three volumes of main
currents were first printed in Paris and
circulated underground in Poland they
were not published legally in Poland
until 2000 in the intervening years the
book has been translated into many
languages including Chinese the last
time I checked however only the first
two volumes which take the story of
Marxism through the death of Len
had been published in France the third
volume which deals with Stalinism and
its and its offshoots including sainted
New Left thinkers like Louis Altos arrow
and Sartre is still waiting for a French
translation why perhaps Kolakowski
speculates because its publication would
provoke such an outrage among French
leftists that the publishers were afraid
to risk it
the Australian philosopher David stove
once observed that as an item on the
intellectual agenda Marxism is scarcely
even a joke Marxism is a fearsome social
and police problem but so was the drug
trade
it is a fearsome political problem but
so is Islamic fundamentalism but an
intellectual problem he said Marxism is
not any more than the drug trade or
Islamic fundamentalism so how
interesting the Kollek offski should
have devoted 1500 pages of main currents
of Marxism as well as dozens of essays
to its Genesis its permutations it's
horrifying record of mass murder in a
1995 essay called why the what is left
of socialism he apostrophized as Karl
Marx as a powerful mind a very learned
man and a good German writer I feel
constrained to add that if Marx can be
said to be a good writer it is in the
highly-qualified sense that the curat
and the famous story said that his
breakfast egg was good but only good in
parts
the Communist Manifesto the theses on
Feuerbach the German ideology contains
some powerful writing but have you
looked into Das Kapital or the Guru and
Risa lately like most of Marx's writing
they should carry a surgeon general's
warning against attempting to operate
heavy machinery after reading yet in the
end I suspect that Kolakowski would have
agreed with David stove he did not
endorse Marxism as an intellectual
phenomenon rather he took it seriously
as a product of human spiritual striving
perverted striving perhaps but
nevertheless heartfelt and deeply
perhaps inextricably ingrained in the
human character that's why we have to
take it seriously this involved him in
the complicated historical itinerary
looking for the origin of dialectic
Holocaust he took readers back not only
to the soteriology of Platonists as I've
mentioned but also to the entire library
of classical and Christian thinkers he
provided a lofty vantage point from
which to regard the sage who assured his
audience in the endlessly quoted snippet
from the theses on Feuerbach that
hitherto philosophers have only
interpreted the world the point is to
change it meister eckhart nicholas of
cuza loom as large and kholokov skews
exposition of marx as do the proletariat
the labor theory of value and the
contradictions of capitalism he does not
give Marxist the Bennett Bark's ism the
benefit of the doubt exactly but he does
give it the benefit of patient scrutiny
and the highest level of historical
intelligence and philosophical acumen
the results of that scrutiny are
devastating perhaps the most grotesque
aspect of Marxism intellectual
pretension is its claim to scientific
rigor and one typical of fusion angles
insisted that the social laws
Marxism claimed to have laid bare were
no less objective than geological
deposits part of what it means to be a
science is to be able to make verifiable
predictions about the behavior of the
phenomena one is studying but Marxism
has proven to be completely barren as an
instrument of social understanding or
prediction this does not mean as
Kolakowski points out that Marxist
theories have not been useful
it's just that their usefulness has been
confined entirely to providing a set of
slogans that were supposed to justify
and glorify communism and the slavery
that inevitably goes with it the truth
is that all of Marx's major predictions
have turned out to be wrong he said that
societies based on a market economy
would suffer spiraling class
polarization and the disappearance of
the middle class yet every society lucky
enough to enjoy the fruits of a market
economy shows that Marx was wrong about
that Marx predicted the growing
immiseration and an impoverishment of
the working class in capitalist
societies actually he didn't merely
predict that it would happen he
predicted with Hegelian owlish ness that
would happen necessarily and inevitably
but the opposite has happened indeed as
colic offski notes and the second
addition of capital marx updated various
statistics and figures but not those
relating to workers wages those figures
if updated would have contradicted his
theory now Kolakowski touches here on an
aspect of Marx's work that I think has
not received sufficient attention I mean
it's casual but shocking mendacity when
the facts didn't fit his theory Marx
simply disregarded them this helps to
account for the curious fact that
refutation and contradiction things that
might convince
a dispassionate observer to change his
mind leave the true believing Marxist
entirely unruffled whatever else one can
say about it
Marxism is surely one of the most in
pervious systems of thought ever devised
it is also one of the most protein it is
always as Kolakowski notes been able to
change content from one situation to
another and crossbreed with other
ideological traditions in part this is a
testimony to its intellectual
adaptability but it is also as I just
noticed noted a testimony to its
mendacity thus we find Marx right into
Friedrich Engels in 1857 about an
election prediction that he is he had
made it's possible that I shall make an
ass of myself Marx acknowledged but in
that case one can always get out of it
with a little dialectic I have of course
so worded my proposition as to be right
in either way nice work if you can get
it and Marx and his heirs got a lot of
that work Marx predicted the inevitable
revolution of the proletariat mark that
the inevitable revolution of the
proletariat that's the very motor of
Marxism take away the proletarian
revolution and you neuter the theory but
there have been no proletarian
revolutions ever the Bolshevik
Revolution as Kolakowski points out had
nothing to do with Marx's Marxian
prophecies it's driving force was not a
conflict between the industrial working
class in capital but rather was carried
out under slogans that had no socialist
let alone Marxist content the slogans
enforced then were peace and land for
peasants Marx said that in a capitalist
economy untrammeled competition would
inevitably squeeze profit margins
eventually and very soon the economy
would grind to a halt and capitalism
would collapse well take a look at the
capitalist economies in the hundred and
fifty years since mark
wrote that profit margins evaporated
Marx thought that when they matured
capitalist economies would hamper
technical progress and communist
societies would support it obviously the
opposite is true
no Marxism has been as wrong as it is
possible to be wrong for a theory
addicted to the self deification of
mankind it continually bears witness to
that farcical aspect of human bondage to
calico ski adduced why then it was
Marxism like moral catnip not so much
among the proposed beneficiaries the
working classes who bore the brunt of
its immiseration effects but among the
educated elite why well beguiling
simplicity was part of it one of the
causes of the popularity of Marxism
among educated people call it coughs
keynotes was the fact that in its simple
form it was so very easy Marxism like
Freudianism and Darwin Darwin anism and
Hegelian ISM is a one key fits all Locke
philosophy all aspects of human
experience can be referred to the
operation of a single governing process
which thereby offers the illusion of
universal explanation Marxism also spoke
powerfully to mankind's unsatisfied
utopian impulses it is certainly true
that free-market societies are far from
perfect think of how much conflict they
abet how many desires they leave
unsatisfied
can we not imagine a world beyond those
tensions and conflicts in which we could
realize our full human potential without
competition without scarcity without
want a society in which as Marx famously
put it in the German ideology the
alienating division of labor has been
overcome and anyone can do one thing
today and another tomorrow hunt in the
morning fish in the afternoon rear
cattle at night and be a critic after
dinner just as I have a mind well yes of
course we can imagine that but there's a
reason that the etymology of utopia whoo
tapas means no place
koulikov ski shows how mark speaks
powerfully to those under realized and
unrealized unrealizable utopian dreams
Marxism he wrote was the greatest fatty
of the fantasy of the 20th century not
because it offered a better life but
because it appealed to the apparently in
eradicable spiritual cravings of mankind
the influence of marx that Marxism has
achieved he wrote far from being the
result or proof of its scientific
character is almost entirely due to its
prophetic fantastic and irrational
elements Marxism is a doctrine of blind
confidence that a paradise of universal
satisfaction is awaiting us just around
the corner
almost all the prophecies of Marx and
his followers have already been proved
false but this does not disturb the
spiritual certainty of the faithful any
more than it did in the case of
chiliastic sects I believe that the
world was supposed to come to an end
last week wasn't it and when it didn't
whoever was propounding that idea said
well in October it will happen in
October in this sense Marxism performs
the function of a religion and its
efficacy is of a religious character but
but Kalahasti note it's a caricature and
a bogus form of religion since it
presents its temporal eschatology as a
scientific system which religious
mythologies do not purport to be of
course it is not just to mankind
spiritual cravings that Marxism appeals
it also speaks to its inherent thuggish
Ness this point cannot be emphasized too
much these days outside of Russia anyway
Stalin and Stalinism are in
bad odor but we forget the romance that
Western intellectuals indulge for this
mass-murderer we also tend to overlook
the fact that thuggish Ness is an
integral not an accidental feature of
Marxism Marx spoke of the dictatorship
of the proletariat now what was that
well Lenin gives us a clue dictatorship
he wrote in 1906 means unlimited power
based on force not law in case that's
not sufficiently compelling Lenin added
the word scientific the scientific term
dictatorship he explained means nothing
more nor less than authority untrammeled
by any laws absolutely unrestricted by
any rules whatever and based directly on
violence I'm glad that Arthur Herman the
other night reminded us at the romance
about Lenin the supposedly good commie
was completely false in 1917 a hundred
years ago this month
Lenin finally got the chance to show the
world what this theory would look like
when put into action he created a system
Kollek housekey observed and which
depended on the whim of a local party or
police authority any criticism might be
regarded as counter revolutionary and
expose its author to imprisonment or
death hence the importance of terror and
the central ingredient in the
revolutionaries utopian program at least
since ropes Pierre spoke of virtue and
its emanation terror the courts Lenin
wrote in 1922 must not ban terror but
must formulate the motives underline it
legalize it as a principle plainly
without any make-believe the crucial
thing to bear in mind here however is
not the brutality of communist rule what
we make what we might call really
existing communism but it's spurious
Ness and contempt for law this is what
distinguishes ordinary despotism from
its totalitarian counter
a law caller coughs keynotes may provide
draconian penalties for small offenses
without being specifically totalitarian
what is characteristic of totalitarian
law is the use of such formulas as
Lenin's people may be executed for
expressing views that may objectively
serve the interests of the bourgeoisie
this means that the government can put
to death anyone it chooses there is no
such thing as law it's not that the
Criminal Code is severe but that it has
no existence except in name in other
words the very arbitrariness of
communist rule is a coefficient of its
ambition to take total control of life
Lenin said that what socialist implies
above all is keeping account of
everything everything was subject to
regulation from above because nothing
had significance apart from the dictates
of the party in this sense
Marxism is a solution in which the idea
of intrinsic value dissolves into
absolute expediency for the Communists
there is no such thing as impartiality
or disinterestedness because there is no
such thing as an independent object of
value
nothing has inherent significance
because everything acquires value from
its function in the impersonal engine of
utopia Stalin once remarked that the
death of an individual was a tragedy but
the death of a million was only a
statistic what he neglected to add is
that for the communist there is no such
thing as an individual by the same token
there is no such thing as independent
judgment scholarly judicial even
aesthetic judgment our post modernist
literary critics are fond of declaring
that there is no such thing as you you
take your pick intrinsic value
objectivity race sex disinterested this
in partiality even truth all is said to
be socially can
structured none of the traditional
values survived in the universal solvent
of this malevolent frivolousness now
every candidate observer knows that this
frivolousness has landed its partisans
in the cloud cuckoo-land of self
contradictory nihilism but Marx and
Lenin got there before the lit crit
estate for the Marxist art and
literature are not human pursuits guided
by their own rules of achievement on the
contrary they are instruments to be used
for the shifting and arbitrary ends of
the party down with nonpartisan writers
Lenin wrote in 1905 down with literary
supermen literature he said must become
part of the common cause of the
proletariat a cog and a screw in one
single great social democratic mechanism
set in motion by the entire politically
conscious vanguard of the entire working
class what a disaster the key issue is
not partisan politics but rather the
subordinating intellectual life
generally to non-intellectual that is to
say political imperatives the greatest
danger call Akatsuki wrote in an essay
on the university is the invasion of an
intellectual fashion which wants to
abolish cognitive criteria of knowledge
and truths the humanities and social
sciences have always succumbed to
various fashions and this seems
inevitable but this is probably the
first time that we are dealing with the
fashion or rather fashions according to
which there are no generally valid
intellectual criteria indeed it is this
failure the colonization of intellectual
life by politics that stands behind and
fuels the degradation of liberal
education the issue is not so much or
not only the presence of bad politics
rather the issue is the absence of non
politics in intellectual life of the
university as I mentioned Sidney Hook
described main currents of Marxism as
Magisterial in its nimble mastery of
intellectual history
and generous humanity the book has few
equals Kolakowski survey of Marxist
thought is breathtaking in its sweep
from the Bible and the Greeks through
the web of 19th century socialist
thought and the florid dissemination of
Marxist and quasi Marxist ideas in the
new age readouts of the 20th century
Kalahasti has provided the definitive
account of a spiritual political
itinerary gone terribly wrong but
perhaps the most impressive thing about
main currents of Marxism is not color
coughs keys breath or learning but his
economy this is a book from which the
reader benefits from the author's great
powers of distillation it's a long book
fifteen hundred pages in the hands of
most writers however it would have been
much longer koulikov Sookie has an
uncanny ability to seize upon and
express the essential features of the
doctrines he discusses no doubt this is
partly a matter of talent but it is also
a testament to the huge labor not only
of reading but also of sifting and
synthesizing that went into the book
collip Kolakowski gives us not his first
thoughts but his considered judgments
honed of the superfluous anyone who
reads these sobering volumes will come
away with not only an understanding of
the intellectual and spiritual
precursors of Marxism but also a good
grasp of the essentials of classical
Marxist doctrine and its hybridization
in the Soviet Union the Frankfurt School
and other left-wing impulses writing
about the Amorphis new left of the 1960s
for example kala Cosby knows that
although ideological fantasies of the
smoke movement were no more than a
nonsensical expression of the whims of
spoiled middle-class children and while
the extremists among them were virtually
indistinguishable from fascist thugs the
movement did without doubt express a
profound crisis of faith in the values
that had inspired Democratic side
for many decades the new left explosion
of academic youth was an aggressive
movement born of frustration was easily
created a vocabulary for itself out of
Marxist slogans liberation revolution
alienation now we have resistance
apart from this its ideology really has
little in common with Marxism it
consists of revolution without the
working class hatred of modern
technology as such the cult of primitive
societies as a source of progress hatred
of Education and specialized knowledge
sounds pretty familiar doesn't it now to
be an anatomist of totalitarianism is
also to be a connoisseur of freedom its
many beguiling counterfeits as well as
its genuine aspirations the question the
lure the never fulfilled but inescapable
promise of freedom stands at the center
of much of koulikov ski's work in an
essay called the self poisoning of the
open society Kalakaua dilates on an
antinomy of liberalism that beset
Western societies during the Cold War
and is if anything even more pressing
today as we negotiate with what amounts
to a moral war with fundamentalist Islam
and the advent of the new new left of an
Tifa and kindred movements the antinomy
is this
liberalism implies openness to other
points of view even it would seem to
those points of view whose success would
destroy liberalism tolerance to those
points of view is a prescription for
suicide intolerance betrays the
fundamental premise of liberalism namely
openness Kolakowski is surely right that
our liberal pluralist democracy depends
for its survival not only on the
continued existence of its institution
but also on a belief in their value
and widespread will to defend them do we
as a society enjoy that belief do we
possess the requisite will I think the
jury is still out in this questions a
good test is the extent to which we can
resolve that antinomy of liberalism and
a good start on that problem is the
extent to which we realize that the
antinomy is in the business of everyday
life ilusory the openness that liberal
society rightly cherishes is not a
vacuous openness to all points of view
it is not value neutral it need not
indeed cannot say yes to all comers
American democracy
for example affords its citizens great
latitude but great latitude is not
synonymous with the proposition that
anything goes our society like every
society is founded on particular
positive values the rule of law for
example respect for the individual
religious freedom the separation of
church and state and so on Western
democratic society that is to say is
rooted into what Kollek offski calls a
particular vision of the world part of
that vision is a commitment to openness
but openness is not the same thing as
indifference for centuries political
philosophers have understood that the
unbridled lust for equality is the enemy
of freedom that lust underwrote the
tragedy of communist tyranny the rise of
political correctness has redistributed
that lust over a new roster of issues
not the proletariat but the environment
not the struggling masses but so-called
reproductive freedom gay rights the
third-world diversity training and an
end to racism and xenophobia which are
held to be ubiquitous it looks in Marx's
famous MO like history repeating itself
as farce it would be a rash man however
who made no provision for a reprieve of
tragedy thank you
[Applause]
you